uh we're going to wait a f a couple more
minutes representative elmi is
testifying in the same bill that
representative romney testified on
and the committee up there is asking
lots of questions and
therefore the delay
once we get started
it shouldn't
take too long so we only have three
bills to discuss this morning so
no i i have not scheduled a meeting for
next week
but
we will
more likely have a schedule for a
okay
thank you
i'm going to open the
work session on senate bill 318
extending the hours in which games a
chance may be conducted
uh
does anybody else have anything to say
thank you i want to move on senate bill
3 18
on my amendment 1494.
for introducing the bill
well before you let it go straight to
to
an itl without us having the ability to
introduce an amendment
oh there's no way out
oh oh that's right there isn't an ico
sorry
um
okay
on senate bill 318
there are
three amendments
amendment 1464-h
by representative romney
and a rep amendment
1513 by representative brownie but it's
really a representative ames amendment
and then amendment 1494
which is a representative amendment
uh
representative brandy you want to
explain your amendment um i'm not going
to move i'm not going to move my
amendment
representative
do you want me to describe my amendment
right now okay
um
this one was written by
on
sean
whose last name i'm blanking on at the
moment uh my city manager who also spent
a long time as part-time lobbyist for
the nhma in these halls
and knows
an awful lot about municipal law
on and who explained to me that on
pretty much all the
bodies of
the
towns
that he knows
on
do not conduct site evaluations when
they are given a
a notice of
change of use
on
they simply go out and do a
safety inspection to make sure that the
premises are safe for the public
on so
there is no
no new site evaluation that is done when
you have a building that is retail and
part of it becomes a doctor's office or
it becomes a um
a games of chance
place
uh
which then turns from being a poker
place into a machine place
um
so
they do not
um
my
small city does not have
a
um ordinance against
on the hours of use in specific
uh they do in the winter time close
everybody down by 10 p.m
um
because they have to plow
uh there is an ordinance for that
uh
the
this
bill says okay you can open at 8 a.m
instead of 11 a.m
uh until 1 a.m and if you want to go
past 1 am
uh
you go and you have a public hearing
with the town or city
and then the governing body votes on
whether you can go past
you can go to 4 a.m
and the governing body can also
designate the days of the week or
specific dates when such
extension is authorized which makes it a
lot more flexible for everybody
and the towns where
they do not have problems with snow
plowing
and the towns where
the establishment is
well outside of
the
will be quite happy to do this
and the other ones will have to
negotiate during the public hearing
about
how this could be done and when this
could be done because if they're going
to be towing all of the
the
cars that are parked
near this establishment
on at
say 2 a.m
that isn't things are not going to end
well for anybody
so um
i think that this is much more
flexible version of of this bill
and it balances
the rights
of the citizens of those towns
with
and the rights of the city government to
do what it needs to do to keep traffic
flowing
in winter
on with the
thank you
thank you representative anybody else
have any additional
questions or information
relative to 318.
thank you mr chair
service representative i mean
when you when you use the example of no
removal
that wouldn't that apply to every
business and and that it's affected if
it's a with that kind of a street that
has those designations as a major
thoroughfare or whatever that we want to
keep the artery open
every bennett business does
uh have to conform to that in in our
town
on
there are
the only businesses
that
might have a problem with that
are the ones i was talking about before
the
shelter
for
substance abuse the shelter for domestic
abuse
and the fire department
uh
the
others are not located there this is not
a major thoroughfare this is on
the town green
the speed limit is 25 miles an hour
and uh the parking is all around
this parking of the city center is all
around this
building
including some of it well i guess it
isn't quite under it
but
um
so
the park it's the parking lots that have
to be open for the businesses
by the time that they open which is
sometimes before 8 o'clock in the
morning
anybody else
or before
excuse me i apologize i didn't introduce
these
members that are substituting
um
substituting for representative yearly
substituting for representative mary
griffin
substituting for
representative mary hacken phillips is
substituting for amanda college
is representative bill hatch
and representative
waltz
thank you so because i'm a sub and i'm
not here i've been here but i'm not here
as often as the rest of you i i actually
have a legitimate question and that is
um we're not a home rule state and my
question is without one of the three
amendments that i have seen
do the municipalities have the authority
to pass ordinances that govern these or
do they need us to add this in with an
yes the authority already exists
and this was uh just in case
let's put it in
kind of a thing
uh
that's why
it already exists we know we know that
municipalities
uh have limited locations in the town or
wherever you know in the example of
salem
where charitable gaming locations can be
to have the ability we heard testimony
from
the lottery
director executive director
that yes there's no restriction for a
town to not place an ordinance to limit
whatever they want to limit
related to these
so
you know the question we debated this
last week whether or not we need an
amendment or not
um we thought it wouldn't hurt
but
you know
we'll see how what the outcome of the
vote is today
representative
thank you mr chairman it already exists
but you are grandfathered
our place was in a floral shop within a
and
there is um
they they came in without
any requirement
except the safety inspection
as a poker room
and now we are talking about extending
the hours as as far as on
i can determine and certainly my account
my city manager
um who knows a lot about these things
on
said that
that we would
need
permission
to be able
to
do
to change
on this entity or any entity that was
already there to to change their ability
to
and i don't know we need need
people who know more about municipal
uh law to talk to us about this
representative waltz
thank you so traditionally
under the law
municipalities can regulate time place
manner hours noise those kinds of things
by passing this bill we are taking away
from the municipality the authority to
regulate the time it appears
unless this is a local option
and i don't see it as saying that i see
that we are commanding that everybody
gets to do this until four in the
morning and i would suggest that perhaps
it may make sense to um do this but do
it with a local option so that if a
community if the if a gaming facility is
in a residential area and it's becoming
problematic after 1am then a
municipality has the authority to to
deal with those kinds of things so i
understand the advantage of leaving them
open but i'm concerned by the fact that
we are taking away from the municipality
the ability to regulate those kinds of
things
right
thank you mr chad i'm just going to
repeat some of what we've already said
in public testimony but as i've said
before i'm a zoning board chair i've
been on been on the zoning for a decade
now
site plan reviews are done with
businesses that come into town we just
had one for an auto
auto dealership auto repair place was
coming in during that site plan review
the things you were talking about
the hours the the parking the health and
safety issues are all addressed in the
site plan review
so when a business submits a site plan
review to a planning board it says our
hour operations are going to be from 10
am to 6 pm
that's part of the site plan that's
approved if they want to change those
hours there's an obligation that they
come back in front of the planning board
and say we're changing our hours of
operation because the site plan was only
allowed from 10 to six
so again i i think between the health
and safety code the parking code the
noise enforcement code all of these
options are available to towns and i'm
not sure that adding another rule that
towns aren't using anyway it sounds like
as helps anybody um and and and make
another exemption especially in this
situation where we're doing a specific
carve out for a specific industry which
i think is wrong um and so what i'm
saying is i from my hat as a zoning
board chair the rules already exist for
municipalities to be able to do what
they want to do they can set parking
requirements they can set health and
safety requirements they can set
all kinds of hours of operation
requirements i did it for uh for a
gravel pit that wanted to go in our
community and we set the hours of
operation somebody complained because
they were outside the hours of operation
on a saturday morning we sent the zoning
guy out he looked at he said sure enough
it is and we sent him a cease and desist
and so towns have the ability to set
time place manner parking health and
safety codes lighting codes there's all
kinds of things that we can do for
businesses so i i think adding another
rule that
that when they're not taking advantage
of the rules that already exist doesn't
make any sense
i would agree representative lang and i
certainly understand those kinds of
things but i would suggest that the
wording of this amendment removes that
discretion from municipalities and i
find that concerning
any further discussion on three one
eight
representation
thank you you are talking about
businesses that have their own buildings
i am talking about multi-use large
buildings which industrial old
industrial towns have got a lot of
and uh they are multi-use
uh we didn't have anything like a poker
parlor in that building before it came
in
without a problem with
with a safety inspection
and that's all we
do
because it's a multi-use building the
main occupant at this point is village
pizza
on
there is a large basement which i think
they're going to ask to expand into that
doesn't get tenants very often
but it was a very small floral shop
that folded and the poker place moved in
and there was a safety inspection
and at that point we do not have the
right to talk about
ours
and such
any further discussion on 318
representative ames
[Music]
yeah i'm not going to talk
any length on this but uh
i i i
agree with what representative walsh has
said i think this bill and in making a
specific reference to a period of
operation
that's allowed has uh
the potential because i don't know i'm
no expert in municipal law the potential
of being interpreted
uh when challenged by some disgruntled
butter and that's going to happen
um
as a uh an action by the state that has
taken away
the discretion of the municipality
essentially what
representative walsh was saying i
as if this bill goes forward without
amendment
i ask that the report at least
state the committees understanding
or position
that
municipalities would retain discretion
to
set different hours of operation
any further discussion
mr chairman there's just one more thing
i wanted to add which is i understand
there are eight more locations now
which will not be able to apply
to expand their operations
for another uh three years i think it is
now but then they will be i don't know
where these locations are but
some of them may also be in old mill
towns
and would have the same
problem because people are trying to put
new businesses into
old buildings that
perhaps and waltz
thank you i was just looking uh there's
an amendment that's in the room i'm not
really sure whose amendment this is
anymore though it says abrami on the top
15 13 and 1513 clarifies that
municipalities continue to have the
hours
um
the authority to do the hours it's the
only thing the amendment does
given that
i
at least two lawyers in the room are
concerned that
the
bill as drafted removes the authority
from the municipality i see no harm in
passing 1513 that clarifies that the
municipality retains the authority to
regulate ours
i just don't want the this to go through
and and as representative ames said
later on three or four years from now in
the courts you have somebody disgruntled
bring it to the courts and have a fight
over it there should be no question
municipalities still have the authority
to regulate the hours so i would suggest
that somebody in this room
i would if i could have the authority
but i don't think i do introduce
at this point in time we're in a work
session
any further
discussion on the amendment that
representative almy had brought up which
representative tucker
uh could i ask you uh representative
elmi
amendment
15 13 would be adequate
since it
apparently removes a concern of some
members of the committee
it's 15 13 15 13. um i would i would be
okay with that one great that's good to
okay um
any further discussion saying none then
i'm going to
open the executive session and
representative gisette
thank you mr chairman i move out to pass
representative deciding on speaking
emotion
certainly we i won't belabor this but
we've heard much
discussion and testimony in relation to
why it's advantageous to not only the
charities the state and the operators to
extend these hours in the workforce here
in new hampshire so um
this has come to us from the senate as
written
and i believe it's a good piece of
legislation for all involved
thank you any further this discussion
representative should move on
yeah
i will move amendment on 1513
since people seem to prefer that one
so you're moving amendment 15 13
yes
which provides the flexibility needed by
towns and
small cities especially on that will be
on
be
having to deal
with the uh secondary effects of the
business being open far into the morning
hours
especially in winter but also
on due to the
parking problems that are involved in
some of them
may i speak to my second
yes
this amendment does only what
representative lang says already happens
it just puts it in writing to make it
clear it doesn't change the bill it
doesn't change the intent of the bill it
just clarifies the language to do what
representative lang says
everybody wants it to do
so i i don't see that it should be
controversial because all it does is
recognize the authority of the town to
is not known as uh this is a point of
order mr chairman we were talking to
representative alame's amendment and
that's what we were going to move in on
and now we're talking about another
amendment i would like some
clarification from the chairs to what
we're doing
we were in work session
discuss all three amendments the first
two amendments were waved out
we discussed representative allen's
amendment
and then represented walls in the
discussion of that brought up uh
amendment
1513h
which says it's a representative romney
but it's really a representative ames
amendment
yeah i just like to clarify that the one
thing that this does make a difference
for
is for the situations in
in places where you move
a
um a new business into
a multi-use building
which is mostly going to be occurring in
old mill towns some of them are pretty
small some of them are are
fairly large um and
manchester probably doesn't have a
problem because they have a very clear
downtown
uh which
uh
they already have to deal with
but for those of us that are in between
where the downtown is actually also a
residential district and also
uh
all of the parking is concentrated in
that downtown area
and we have to do snowplowing and winter
i didn't even think about this till my
my city manager talked to me about it
on we need some flexibility in order to
be able to figure out
with that business in a public hearing
how
this is going to work because
we
don't
do
site evaluations of pieces of buildings
we only do them
for the whole building when the whole
building was created and that whole
building was created as a multi-use
retail
any further discussion on amendment 15
13 h
president lyon thank you again i'm going
to vote against this amendment we're
creating a unique carve out for a unique
business business structure which i
think is inappropriate we know we heard
in testimony that the town of hampton
beach i think it was already has some
like one o'clock curfew laws and so that
that limits some of these organizations
to do certain things so but it's a broad
it's a broad uh ordinance it's not
target it's not a targeted ordinance
saying on this particular industry we're
going to make special rules so i think
that that's a bad policy to get into
where we start making special rules for
special industries like this that are
that could be subject so i'm going to be
voting against this the towns already
have the authority it's wasted words of
represented waltz
thank you well if that's the case we
shouldn't be passing this underlying law
because that is for a specific industry
and it's setting times for a specific
industry so if we don't want to set
times for a specific industry let's just
itl the law but if you're going to pass
the law and set these times for a
specific industry then i think you need
to give the local option
so
you know you can't have it both ways is
what i'm trying to say if we set the
times for the industry we have to give
them a local option or we just don't
pass the bill but it
the argument doesn't cut both ways
representative lange
further discussion
on the amendment
saying none i'm going to ask the court
to call the vote on
the amendment 15 13
h
thank you mr chair we will begin the
voting on amendment 15 13 h with
representative abrami the motion is
ought to pass by the way
on the amendment we're talking about the
representative thomas
no
representative renzullo
representative giusette no
representative lang nope clerk votes no
representative genigion no
representative nunes no representative
spillsbury no
representative tudor no
representative aaron
no
representative almi
yes representative ames
yes
i'd like to welcome back representative
southworth it's good to see you again
thank you yes
thank you representative malloy yes
repre the honorable representative
thomas c schomburg yes mr clerk thank
you sarah representative tucker yes
representative gomarlo
yes
representative hatch
representative walls yes
representative murphy yes
about being 12 to 10 the uh
the motion about to pass on the
saying no other amendments
any further discussion on
saying none i'm going to ask the clerk
senate bill 318 that
fn and the motions ought to pass thank
you mr chair
we will begin the voting on airspeed 318
with the motion of all to pass we'll
begin with representative abrami yes
representative thomas yes representative
renzullo yes representative doucette yes
representative lang yes the clerk votes
yes representative genigion yes
representative nunez yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes representative
aaron
yes
representative almi
no
representative ames oh
representative southworth no
representative malloy no
the honorable thomas c schomburg
yes
representative tucker
representative hatch no
representative walls
no
thank you representative murphy nope
the vote been 14 to 8.
has ought to pass the motion carries
recommendation will be otp
okay
all right i'm going into a work session
on
senate bill 343 establishing a committee
the study room occupancy tax revenues
and fees
and the formula for distribution to
municipalities
does anybody have any additional
information
that they want to present to the
committee
saying none then i'm going to go into
representative lange i move itl on
representative lang moves out itl
and do we have a second representative
nunes
mr chair real quick just a comment the i
think you hit the nail on the head when
we had our public hearing in our
discussion on this last time um this
opens the doors for things like how do
we apportion business profits tax how do
we apportion gas tax how do we apportion
all the limited state taxes that we have
um and and i think that's again these
are state taxes for state purposes for
all the hampshire citizens so i think
the equitable distribution that's done
now based on population is appropriate
thank you further discussion
representative romney followed by
representative hatch
i think we heard in uh
in testimony from the dra that
in in this
it's the perception over the years has
been that we haven't even looked at
something like this because rims wasn't
in place the more advanced computer
system that's now there
but it turns out that's not really the
case this could have been done a long
time ago
and uh
but
this kind of a bill but this is the
study but the underlying thing is a bill
where municipalities have
the opportunity well the first they want
a greater proportion of the uh taxes for
for one thing
mainly rooms tax
and then the the other thing was that
the study was a two dollar municipal
occupancy tax which is a slippery slope
by the way
that we've that we've killed in the past
not giving the municipalities the
ability to tax that way we don't allow
our municipalities to tax
this way
and uh i don't think there's really
anything much to study here if someone
wants to move something like this they
should move a bill
that does one of one or the other
uh i don't think we need to study it
anymore
we've
we've beaten this to death over the
years thank you
representative hatch
thank you mr chair um i just
really disagree with it yelling this uh
in 2008 i believe it was
when the economy
crashed
we changed how this
tax was utilized and how it was
apportioned to communities
and we took back
much of what used to go to communities
and
having been here for
a number of years when these discussions
did and didn't take place
it's something that is still
unresolved
for many of our constituents and many of
our communities
i suspect most of us have has heard at
one time or the other
how
maybe their community is not
receiving an appropriate a
appropriate amount
from this tax compared to what they
contribute to it and a myriad of other
things and and i'm not here to say which
is right or wrong but i am here to say
that when we changed how this was
apportioned
when we took back from many of the
communities
um
monies they re used to get
i think as a body
we have an obligation
to do
what was stated by those before us
that when things change
this will be looked at and it can be
addressed as
far as the inequities
of how this is distributed because there
are inequities there are bases how this
is distributed that really don't have a
lot to do with how it's gathered so um
just with that i i really can't
support an itl and i'm really
disappointed
that we won't at least take the
opportunity
to look at this and look at it in depth
and and give it to serious consideration
um that it deserves thank you mr chair
send none then i'm going to
oh representative elmi
thank you i
the need not to distribute this back
just to the places that uh
raised it
but we do have a problem which has been
hidden within the problem with the
education property tax
on
and
and the education funding
that
there are
cities and large towns that act as the
service centers social service centers
and
other service centers that are
non-profit
on
four surrounding towns that do not have
and
the two dollar municipal occupancy fee
not a tax it would have been related
as it had gone in in a number of times
too
on the
the extra costs to the municipalities of
this
on
is something that i've been working on
for a fair amount of time because
lebanon is one of those urban hubs that
has this problem
on
and
on this is on that piece of it line 20
is from uh my senator's bill
uh which the senate combined into there
so on i'm going to be voting against but
in general i agree with you
on the bill
thank you
further discussion
representatives
yeah i just want to say that i will be
voting for the itl motion uh i
i think that
the information is always good to get
and we can work on fine-tuning what we
get in terms of source of
revenues but there's a
direction
in which this bill points which i
disagree with
uh for the reasons really that
representative langston stated i
think the revenues that are raised from
attacks like this are
are then
for
distribution according to action by the
state and should be uh
occasionally
it's appropriate to earmark but
as a general rule i try to avoid that
so uh
that's why i will vote against it i'd
also note that as a practical matter
we're uh now
in uh
yeah where the heck are we in mid-april
and uh
we're headed into more time while this
bill
uh gets to the end of its uh
trio to enactment and if it were to be
enacted we'd be into the mid-summer
and we're in an election year and i
doubt very much that any significant
study will happen
uh in that remaining time and i just
assumed see it uh
set aside and if there's a lot of
interest in uh
in uh doing this
uh representative romney
yeah i just i just want to comment that
in terms of us studying this bill
there's been five bills since 2015 of
this kind
to do actually act on on this uh not a
study and we have a history in this
committee of of forming subcommittees
and i know there are several at least
several subcommittees that have
looked at this in depth over the years
so
again i i think this is i think we
understand the issues
it's just a matter of whether we have
will and ways of means to pass a bill
that does something that
is being requested to be studied here
thank you
any further discussion
saying none i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the vote
on the motions i tl
thank you mr chair
we'll begin the voting on senate bill
343 the motion is itl
representative abrami yes
representative thomas yes representative
renzullo yes representative doucette yes
representative lang yes
bershteen votes yes representative
genigean yes
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury yes representative tudor yes
representative aaron
yes
representative army
representative ames
yes
representative southworth yes
representative malloy yes
the honorable thomas c schomburg no
representative tucker no
representative hatch no
representative walls yes
representative murphy yes
the vote on the motion of itl is 17-5
the motion passes
okay i'm going to open the work session
relative to the net operating loss
carryover under the business profits tax
do we have any more new information that
mr chair new representative
schamberg hamburger
uh
i've got some concerns about house bill
the concerns i have is for the small
business comp community in new hampshire
now my general overall view of
senate bill 435 is
one portion of the bill is an
apportionment fix for the big companies
all right but for the 72 plus thousand
small business owners that pay between
zero
and ten thousand dollars
in taxes paid from data from 2019
the small businesses
that
do not
apportion
the proposed n
l nold and senate bill 435 is not a fix
for them
my biggest overall concern
is that under existing law the small
business owner can fully recover and
utilize the nolds before reporting any
taxable income
under senate bill 435 the small business
owner
nold would be capped at 80 percent and
this is where my concern is
this is no fix for the small business
owner trying to recover
from the past two years of covid
restrictions or the business turndowns
what this does is handicaps
this bill would handicap especially the
the survival
of small businesses living off
a small
profit margin
on the elimination of the bpt nol
double apportionment
fiscally it will produce a decrease to
the general
and educational trust fund
as stated by
the dra
third
what house bill 435 is also asking in
this bill is to make changes without
data
and the effect upon the state revenue
for state
programs the state switched to
market-based sourcing
we have yet to see if the bpt
is losing or gaining revenue without the
federal stimulus monies that have been
inserted
we have
or will refund
taxes for businesses that got pp
stimulus we do not know exactly how much
anywhere between 90 and 100 million
dollars over maybe a two or three year
time period and now
the state
is moving to the single sales factor
that this committee wish to hold off
until 2025-26
so that data could be compared by the
dra
to the prior property payroll sales
formula through market-based sourcing
we i think all want our small businesses
to survive
they are the largest employers
as i look across the room to
my friends on the other side my business
friends on the other side
i am suggesting maybe we have an
amendment
to assist the small business owners
and i hope that my friends across the
aisle that are pro-business would be
willing to work maybe to
either decouple through an amendment
uh the 80 cap
or
adopt
the 80 percent cap
and have an indefinite carry forward or
maybe there's a third option or fourth
option
that is possible
but to come together so that we can give
our small business owners a break and
maybe and level the tax
field
between
big and small
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative schoenberg
and representative rodney
okay can i
thank you mr chair um
representative schoenberg so
you're okay with section one of the bill
is that correct
yes i am i'm not happy but i'm okay okay
so we're we're really talking about the
second section of the bill and basically
pretty much the 80
part
true so
and all the 80 part does is is extends
they they can eventually all businesses
can eventually take all their net
operating loss
yes they can
over time
okay but this just slows it down a bit
by having the 80 they can't take
it extends it out okay
so
uh i'm not necessarily opposed to your
thought
about trying to protect
smaller businesses
uh
this is interesting because you know
with this second part of the bill
it actually
actually
slows the flow of revenue it is more
with like five 4.5 million estimated by
the dra
that would
would
uh stay with the state and not go to
businesses
so
um
you know so i see this to do
what you're proposing is either get rid
of the 80 totally and which we don't
have just don't adept up the
new federal guideline for that
particular thing
or
you know
uh do something that we we put a tier in
here
for smaller businesses
and that's something we need to discuss
i guess
thank you
representative thank you we have carolyn
in the room so i might have a question
before she runs away to the washington
dc um i want to make sure i'm clear
because because what was said i i was a
little confusing so my understanding of
what this does with the 80 carryover is
if you have a business in the first year
that lost a hundred thousand dollars in
the second year they made a hundred
thousand dollars
they would be able to take eighty
thousand dollars in the first year and
apply that towards their so they're only
paying taxes on
twenty thousand dollars is that correct
and then the third year they could use
the balance of that twenty thousand
dollars assuming they made the same
hundred thousand dollars they could then
take that same twenty thousand dollar
loss put it into the third years and
they would only pay taxes on eighty
thousand dollars is that the clearance
thing so they they get the full use of
the net operating loss over the course
of it it's just spread out
so i think so she's shaking her head yes
for anybody who has doesn't see her on
the camera so mr chair i guess the way i
look at this is this is actually helps
the state with revenues relative to
flattening
problems right so again if you have a
bunch of businesses take a bunch of
losses and they take all the losses in
the first year that's going to tank our
revenues
in one year
whereas by using the 80 factor
when they go to take that loss
they get the full loss they just got to
take it over a longer period of time
which helps our revenues stabilize so i
looked this as a tax stabilization bill
that helps us with businesses even
through rough times and when they come
out of those rough times be able to
still use 100 of their nol
but at the same time it doesn't bang the
state as hard on its revenues so i look
at it as a good bill for stabilization
with state revenues to help us make it
through those hard times um and and i'll
be voting in favor of them
mr chair
representative
i'm glad you're concerned about the
state but what about the small business
owner that that needs that money
uh that small margin to stay in business
to keep his employees
employed
paying and buying
uh products here in new hampshire
so that more revenue can come in i i i
i'm having a hard time
following your i understand what you're
saying
but i'm having a hard time following why
do you not want to
assist the
small business owner now
just one one quick response one thing
remember is that new hampshire is an
outlier in this
right so i think we heard 49 other
states do it this way with the 80
and adopting that federal rule right so
it makes it more compliant and makes
businesses or move that are dealing
either whether it's a multi-state
business or otherwise again it
standardizes states so we're not this
one-off in the entire country so you
know while i recognize that and again we
are giving them the benefit which is
only given 80 of the benefit that last
20 percent they still get they just got
to wait one more year for us so i don't
think we're you know i i don't think
we're hurt it's that it's it's as
drastic as you say i guess is my
statement
the um problem
is
how do
how do you define that small business
the point where they get the exemption
or not
if we were in a maybe a study committee
we might be able to come up with a
a good answer on that
representative
almy
thank you on my thought on this was on
250 000
of net on
taxable profit
uh before the nold
on
i don't know if they've got some idea in
dra or could create it of
how much that would actually lose us of
this money
because a lot of this money comes from
but
the example we were given by mr seglio
is on for a two-year recession
and it took till
they
would be paying
on
it would take them three years four
years to get out of this
on
this cost
and if it was a
bigger loss and a bigger recession
on as we had
n08
to 11.
then
they
they come to a point where
they really
uh
a small portion of this money disappears
completely as i understand it
but
on
the it's the small businesses that don't
have a cushion
usually to take them through this unless
they've got somebody working another job
that didn't lose the job and things like
that
and so
it's
it's the and
our our tax we have to remember that our
business taxes
are a much larger part of our budget
than in any other state
and a lot of them regard their business
taxes as
as we regard our communications tax
so
presumably their businesses are not
being taxed that much through that
area if we were to do that we would not
have a government left because we don't
we need more than a guideline of
250 000
we need a better definition of a small
business
because a lot a huge
could have a year where they have 240
and they would get
the advantage
if you're trying to protect the small
business it should be concentrated to
the small business
um
represent ames did you
did you have an idea of how to define
i really hadn't thought about that no
i i think if we're going to go down this
road then
we need to use
the next
two weeks to
develop an amendment that
would be have a reasonable uh
cut off basically we're talking about
cut off at
see if see if that
indeed would work and
the other comment i make is
responding to some of the discussion is
that uh
that we wouldn't have a 10 year limit if
we didn't
or
it used to be a shorter limit if we
some businesses might go up to that
limit we wouldn't have extended it out
to 10 years
and uh
the federal government wouldn't have
extended it out indefinitely if they
didn't
if there wasn't some evidence that some
businesses
needed that extended period of time so
if you if you drop down to 80
uh there's a good likelihood it strikes
me that there will be some businesses
that will year after year take up to 80
of their operating loss
and come out at the end of 10 years with
still some
operating
up to 80 of their profit i meant to say
will come up to the end of 10 years and
still have some operating laws that they
haven't taken and now they've run out
i think that's inevitable that's just a
matter of math and reality
and just reading between the lines of
why there's been this pressure at the
federal level to
go to an unlimited time limit
so those are my comments
representative gamalo
uh thank you representative ames said a
couple of the points i wanted to make
um but i'd like to point out that
there's according to this chart 18
states that have conformed
and
what
mr eusiglio's recommendation was if we
kept the 80 cap was to go to the
indefinite carry forward period like
representative ames just said
and i believe we already had an
amendment in the works to eliminate
lines 5 to 22
so maybe we could just add that one
piece and not worry about what a small
business is or not but just say that um
we have an indefinite carry forward
period instead of
trying to make it too complicated
rob's in a line
so i did submit that amendment but i
think we all got the email from david
saying with the rush that amendments are
being delayed
out of ols so we didn't have it in time
for this meeting so
um again i well i would love to clean up
the language i'm happy to move it
forward the way it is and not delay
again the house's scheduling is
important and getting bills out of
committee is important and i i don't
think just cleaning up the language is
enough to delay this bill so i we we
postulated the idea of moving it to 20
years and it felt like the committee had
no appetite for that
when we discussed it the last at the
last meeting so the only thing the
amendment would have done was strike a
through d
and that was a cleanup language so i i'm
happy to move the bill forward the way
representation
thank you we've been having this
discussion for a number of years as
other states and the federal government
on
at least here in new hampshire
on when we moved to 10 years
i think we were at two
[Music]
and
it might have been five
but the general idea was other states
are doing it we have to do it too it
wasn't really anything else
and the
the
advice against it which was really
extreme towards the beginning of our
time uh commissioner blatzos was still
there he didn't have very good he didn't
have any uh analysis to back this up
but on he was afraid that it was going
to cost a huge amount of money
uh with all of the data collection that
we've done we can't predict the future
as dra has said and so they can't tell
us how much we might lose or not lose if
we went out to indefinite
on from 10 years
and
the only way that i can see that
we would have businesses operating with
such huge operating losses and still
able to be part of it is
this on sharing of intangibles
that they
can a large corporation creates a
business inside of new hampshire which
is
basically
uh sending all of its profits out to new
jersey or what not they wouldn't do new
jersey to florida
and
and uh reporting them there by way of of
selling on
their
brand
to the place in
on
in florida or something like that and
then having to pay royalties to them
so
um so that that is something that would
allow very large businesses to do that
kind of thing i don't think any small
business could possibly
manage that
but
thank you mr chairman
i'm comfortable with the balance
um
as the senate has presented the bill
to us and i'll be supporting it
i think as a practical matter
10 years provides ample time
to
recapture your losses and apply them
against future gains even with the 80
percent
as to representative southworth's
concern about small business which i
think we all share the concern is a
generalized matter
let's just remember that last year in
sb2 we took a very significant step
uh in that direction by nearly doubling
the filing threshold and so i would
venture that
the list of small businesses that
representative southworth is and excuse
me
pardon me
is referring to
which is a 2019 list
i would bet that a very large number of
those taxpayers are now alleviated
altogether
for the discussion um
with the dra
representative bromley
yeah uh following on to what
representative pillsbury said
that change in the threshold
really
means that there are a lot more
businesses that are not paying the
bpt
correct
that's right i don't have my fiscal
analysis from the those bills but i
believe in that analysis we actually
named the number
of bills that would no longer be
required to pay and i believe in both
instances it was in the thousands
because we raised both the bpt and the
bet threshold last session right right
and then
i know uh devin
created a document
that i have in front of me here that
shows the number of businesses by the by
the categories you know how we break it
by the amount of uh
of tax
and yes i mean it it this does seem to
say that
the adjusted uh business profit tax
um
there's definitely benefit for the
double apportionment for all size
businesses and i don't think we're
debating that we're debating the second
part of the bill
um
that it appears that
for what representative schomburg is
saying
is that yes there there's a lot because
there's a lot more smaller businesses
there that are that have their profits
are less than a hundred hundred thousand
uh
in which the tax would have to be
paid
um
i don't know i i'm trying to understand
i guess i'm trying to say
the whole break point issue first is
that constitutional for us to come up
with a
an arbitrary number
are we treating
that tax differently for different
businesses is that a problem
um
gosh i would hate to wax about the
constitutionality of that um
but i think the one thing i would say
was is that the conversation about
conformity and conforming to the
internal revenue code
um
is generally for sort of low impact
changes a conversation about
administrative ease and clarity
and so i would suggest that perhaps
creating
a threshold for taxpayers where the 80
percent applies to some but not others
may be moving in the wrong direction as
it relates to complexity and it might
not just be better to do nothing
and continue to conform to an old code
rather than conform to the new code for
some taxpayers and the old code for
any further questions for the dra
i do i do so if we decide to take the 80
from what i see from from devon we're
talking about right now that would have
actually
for the first year
would have increased taxes to the state
by 4.5 million
that's that's correct if you did nothing
with conformity um you would forego that
four and a half million dollars in
additional revenue right
so so that's what we're talking about
um if we're if we if we do it the
state's going to get 4.5 million more
dollars
in in the coming years
if we if we just leave we we don't
conform to the federal 85 percent
then uh
you know
then then it's the other way around
ah
okay could i ask one more question yes
do you remember how much
on
reducing
uh increase increasing the floor for
filing cost us last time
i don't have that handy and i don't
recall
yeah because i think on
we were just going up to where inflation
relative to where we were years ago i
can't quite remember what happened in
further questions of the dra
thank you i just wanted to respond to
representative abrami in a moment just
to point out something even though we're
we'd have a um
a four million dollar
plus
with the removal of the
double
apportionment we have an 18 million
dollar
we talked about section one and see
we're an agreement okay but yeah thank
you
then
just i thought maybe we'd do a straw
poll to see if we were ready for that
yet
for those
that want to work on an amendment an
amendment is not existing right now
we would uh
schedule a meeting
we have time for one more meeting
and that would be
if we did it would be the 27th
of this month because i was going to do
it on the 26th but
salem's having their election that day
and so
it would be the 27th
that's a wednesday we'd ask we'd also
have to have the uh
the
committee reports ready that morning too
so we could get it into the calendar
so if you're
interested
in proceeding
with the amendment
one
if you're not interested in proceeding
so we will proceed
with the executive session
uh representative lange
mr chair i move out of pass on house on
senate bill 435 fn
representative lang moves out to pass on
house bill
any further discussion
and we are in an executive session
any further discussion on the amendment
most of the motion to ought to pass
it's tough
um
seeing none and i'm going to ask the
clerk to call the vote
thank you mr chair the bill is senate
bill 435 the motion is all to pass we
will begin the voting with
representative abrami yes
representative thomas yes representative
renzullo yes representative doucette yes
representative lang yes bershteen votes
yes
representative genigion yes
representative nunes yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative tudor yes
representative aaron
yes
representative army
representative ames yes representative
southworth yes
representative malloy yes
the honorable
representative thomas c schomburg for
the 72 000 small business owners no
they appreciate that
representative tucker yes
representative gomarlo yes
yes
representative walls yes
representative murphy
yes
the vote being 21-1 the motion passes
um
do you have an objection i'd like to
make a comment what's that i'd like to
make a comment please
i don't have a question i'd like to make
a comment okay uh let me just finish
this up yep
been
21 to nothing the motion about to pass
passes 21-1 20 21 to
you reversed it no no i will we'll write
a minority report
you will write a minor report so it will
so the minority motion will be out to
pass with an amendment
okay
you're gonna have to work with
it would be for the next calendar so if
you
get me the uh report amendment
monday
that'll give you plenty of time
this monday
is that a better approach mr chairman
if i gave you tuesday
i would like to change from otpa to itl
i can argue that better right now
all right thank you
so tuesday do we still have a firm
commitment on tuesday thursday thank you
representative tucker yeah i i was uh
bewildered when this bill first came
before
us
and
wasn't absolutely sure that i could
quite grasp all its nuances
and i must say that the
witnesses the presentations the
discussion
i feel very comfortable now so i i think
that
it's a
i serve as sort of the
the uh
canary in the
in the mine
and uh
i just think it's it's nice to know the
system works that having a large group
of people
all of whom have different talents and
experiences
does work to make it so
what we're talking about is
understandable yeah it's a constant
learning process for all of us yeah we
have lots of different talent here on
both sides
and i certainly appreciate that i think
everybody else and i just wanted to
comment on that because sometimes it
feels like
overwhelming a little overwhelming but
this it does work and having
uh people from the community
people who are knowledgeable having dra
it really does make it so we can
reach an informed decision
thank you
anything else
if not thanks everybody and we are not
but representative schoenberg you're
mr chair
my blurbs are already in your inbox
you